sur les prochaines blanc valéry giscard
d'estaing en guinée un accueil plus
qu'enthousiaste de toute une population
l'agriculture du sud ouest une région se
prépare à la concurrence de l'arrivée
des pays du sud dans le marché commun le
ladder un outil ultramoderne au service
de la santé et d'explications de martin
à la réunion 1 messieurs bonsoir
l'actualité va si vite que nous avons
trop souvent tendance à oublier sur le
bord de la route ce que nous avons mis
en lumière la veille
c'est le cas d'alain colas je vous en
parlais hier c'est le cas aussi de
l'exode des vietnamiens les images que
je vous propose maintenant sont très
forte elle se passe de tout commentaire
elles ont été tournées quelque part sur
la côte malaise un bateau chargé à ras
bord de réfugiés vietnamiens tentent de
s'approcher du rivage
le bateau va couler vie réfugiés vont
mourir d'autres se préparer à un long
exil des scènes comme cela se reproduise
de semaine en semaine
on me disait
ah bah ouais
dans quatre jours ce sera noël en france
en malaisie au vietnam n'ont pas jugé la
situation politique du vietnam occupe
des motivations de ceux qui le type mais
je crois que par tous les moyens
il faut les aider il ya par exemple ce
comité un bateau pour le vietnam qui se
trouvent 25 rue jaffeux à gennevilliers
dans la région parisienne
la france elle se prépare à fêter noël à
grand-fort d'illumination ce qui a pu
choquer hier par exemple au soir d'une
journée de pagaille déclenchée par la
grande panne de ce que l'histoire
appellera pompeusement le mardi noir
aujourd'hui tout est réparé ou presque
on a simplement maintenu une baisse de
5% dans tout le pays l'edf est
relativement satisfait de la façon dont
tout cela était contenu n'a été
paraît-il bien plus efficace que lors de
pannes semblable à new york ou ailleurs
mais la facture sera lourde mais pas
simple à calculer mais ça représente en
gros une demi journée de perdue pour 200
jours ouvrables de travail en france est
à dire entre deux ou trois milliards de
francs sadi reste aussi l'avenir
comment et vivre ensemble semblables les
violences elles vont consommer un peu
plus cette année que l'année dernière
c'est dans la courbe normale des
productions des consommations
d'électricité
cette consommation devrait donc dépasser
celle de
hier de quelques pourcents 6% à 7% je me
dire quand même nous en parlions tout à
l'heure que ça ne nous pose pas de
problème très grave puisque la dernière
semaine de l'année traditionnellement
est une semaine plus faible que les
semaines précédentes du début le mode
décembre quand se situera donc le
prochain point fort je crois que nous
avons passé une points forts de l'année
78 par contre pour l'hiver à 78,79 nous
retrouverons des semaines et des
journées de très forte consommation pas
semblablement suivant la température
ouvert fin janvier ou début février
une première façon d'éviter les coupures
de courant lors des pointes c'est
d'acheter de l'électricité à l'étranger
c'est possible grâce à des lignes à
haute tension qui nous relie à nos
voisins
voici par exemple ce qui se passe dans
le centre qui s'occupe de ces
transactions internationales celles
filmées lors d'une pâle en italie les
italiens ont perdu entre 2 600 mégawatts
ne demande s'il peut leur fournir 300
mégawatts en secours à partir de
maintenant jusqu'à 20 heures ce soir
est ce que tu peux leur fournir
on doit pouvoir les fournir sur les
halles entre ge et michel villaz rodin
oui non pas le prénom de réseaux non
non le transit sont normaux à plus long
terme d'ici à 1985 il faut fabriquer des
lignes à haute tension et des centrales
électriques mais ce n'est pas si facile
compte tenu des délais d'ici 85 on ne
peut pas faire grand chose on peut
mettre en construction des moyens de
production qui sont des à vienne
expérimenté assez rapide par exemple des
turbines à gaz et peut être quelques
tranches au charbon et puis on peut
développer le réseau intérieur et
développer les interconnexions
internationales et le nucléaire vient le
nucléaire à des délais entre la décision
et la mise en service qui sont 2 6 7 8
ans suivant la longueur des procédures
c'est à dire qu'une décision prise
aujourd'hui d'accélérer le programme
n'aurait pas d'effet avant 1985 86
comment vous pouvez planifier la
consommation dans quelques années à bien
dans le passé s'était battu mansart je
l'avais des habitudes et traditions il y
avait des corrélations entre la
production intérieure et la consommation
pour l'avenir des choses sont plus flous
sont plus aléatoires plus difficiles à
prévoir et je vous citer un exemple ce
que nous pouvons très mal évalué c'est
le désir comment nos différents abonnés
que ce soit les abonnés domestiques
tertiaire ou l'industrie de passer à
l'électricité pour abandonner par
exemple un pétrole qui deviendrait de
plus en plus cher alors il très très
long terme je pense que l'énergie n'est
pas un sujet de préoccupation
particulier parce qu'elle le soleil mais
peut-être n'est-ce pas avec les méthodes
actuelles que l'on résoudra vraiment ce
problème la captation de l'énergie
solaire c'est pour le moyen terme disons
à deux ou trois décennies que l'une
semble les choses sont les plus graves
et je suis de ceux qui pensent que la
seule solution réaliste pour un pays
comme la france qui ne peut pas exporter
trop de devises qui ne peut pas être
trop sous la coupe d'un petit nombre de
pays producteurs
c'est l'énergie
à propos de prévisions cet incident un
permis de découvrir que la bretagne ne
produisait que 20 % de son électricité
tout le reste est d'importer d'ailleurs
le système monétaire européen va
démarrer sous de mauvais auspices
pourtant tout le monde ou presque est au
rendez vous du 1er janvier celui
manqueront les anglais mais ce succès
peut être obéré par l'antagonisme de
paris et de bonnes en matière de
monnaies verte et de montants
compensatoires pierre méhaignerie le
ministre culture n'a pu obtenir et n'a
pu concrétiser aujourd'hui les espoirs
qu'il avait fait naître chez les
présidents
en fait les neuf on refusait de
d'évaluer dans l'immédiat le franc vers
et les cures restera donc à l'écart de
la politique agricole commune
alors philippe châssis en essayant de
schématiser au maximum on peut dire que
les montants compensatoires représente
une sorte de droit de douane d'équipé
oui si vous voulez effectivement en 1959
au départ il faillit c'est de compenser
les variations entre les différentes
monnaies pour empêcher notre école d'une
part et les revenus des agriculteurs de
l'autre de changer trop brusquement et
puis trop souvent aujourd'hui le système
s'est détériorée et pour certains
produits ces montants compensatoires
arrive un double résultat une part
subventionner les produits chers des
pays à monnaie forte comme l'allemagne
et de l'autre tard c'est à dire en fait
pénaliser les produits moins chers des
pays à monnaie faible comme la france
regardez ces deux cochons le cochon
allemand lui ai payé 7 francs 36 à
l'agriculteur allemand
mais lorsqu'il franchit le rhin pour
être vendue en france passe à ces
montants compensatoires dit dans ce
sens-là positif il est payé seafrance r
c'est un prix extrêmement compétitifs
par rapport aux cochons français le
cochon français lui est payé 7 francs 11
à l'agriculteur français et quand il
franchit le rhin pour être vendus en
allemagne
eh bien il perçoit des montants
compensatoires négatif cela est il
arrivé au prix de 8 francs 30 et avril
que son frangin qui est un petit peu
plus rose un peu moins gros et jamais de
plus grosse mais vous comprenez on en
penser qu'à bruxelles la france avec
lumière à l'ombre
davantage la structure sont drôles et
pourquoi avec ces chiffres pourquoi ce
que les allemands tiennent autant ce
système est pourquoi les agriculteurs
bretons sortent de temps en temps leurs
fourches mais effectivement il ya quinze
jours à bruxelles la france avait obtenu
deux choses ou par retour progressif à
l'unité des pratiques cote
et puis de l'autre et bien disparition
progressive des montants compensatoires
alors aujourd'hui donc l'allemagne mais
aussi les pays-bas sprint qui peut tirer
l'oreille est ce que ça veut dire que le
sm le système monétaire européen et est
remis en cause complètement foot et
c'est un petit peu trop tôt pour le dire
en tout cas on attend très rapidement
une réaction de la france et ce que l'on
peut dire c'est que à quelques jours de
la naissance officielle du système
monétaire a pas de pire et bien les
autorités françaises se trouvent
confrontés un assez grave problème pour
l'instant pas de réaction des
agriculteurs français ont on peut
imaginer vous le voyez leur déception
déception qui sera sans doute plus forte
encore dans ce que l'on appelle le grand
sud ouest le grand sud ouest c'est une
notion qu'il faut bien et à intégrer dès
maintenant car je reste souvent vous en
reparler le gouvernement a décidé de
faire un effort particulier pour une
région dont les équipements laissait
parfois à désirer ce grand sud ouest
vous voyez regroupe trois régions de
programmes l'aquitaine le
languedoc-roussillon et le midi par les
pyrénées un parent si je vous dis qu'il
ya une émotion particulière la basse et
à la proche de l'entrée de l'espagne
d'un marché commun l'émotion n'est pas
partagé par tout le monde beaucoup se
réjouissent de cette arrivée met un
certain nombre d'agriculteurs
s'inquiètent
c'est le cas notamment des pyrénées
orientales un département en première
ligne face à celui que certains
appellent l'adversaire créé en 1970 le
marché international saint-charles de
perpignan et la trouée par laquelle
s'engouffrent quotidiennement en france
plusieurs dizaines de camions espagnols
bourré de fruits et légumes
seuls les douaniers français ont ralenti
quelques instants leur trajectoire afin
de percevoir les droits
malgré cela les marchandises sont là à
bombay alors qu'allons nous devenir
les agriculteurs du sud-ouest lorsque
cette production arrivera librement chez
nous nous avons fait des recherches des
reconversions tous nos efforts seront
ils 20
ainsi nous pouvons voir derrière nous et
à côté une vigne et derrière un jean de
salades ce genre de salade et signifie
que l'arrêt petite région à modifier non
seulement sa structure mais aussi ses
apports en argent le vin rouge ne peut
plus nous essayons à tous prié de
regagner le temps perdu et notre
problème actuellement est que si
l'espagne est rentré dans un temps très
court dans le marché commun toutes les
personnes qui ont fait des plans de
développement qui se sont restructurées
c'est à dire par là qu'ils ont fait des
emprunts qui auront auront beaucoup de
difficultés pour les amortir et pour les
payer étant donné que l'espagne n'a pas
les mêmes charges ni sociale ni
d'exploitation connu et c'est bien là le
principal souci des agriculteurs
français leur prix de revient sont
supérieures ainsi le salaire de base
d'un ouvrier spécialisé agricole est de
12 ans 61 de leurs en espagne les de 7 à
8 francs selon la région de plus les
employeurs espagnols ne paient pas de
charges sociales en france la part
patronale dans le régime agricole le
32,19 % du salaire mais ce n'est pas
tout les patrons espagnols pratique des
méthodes dans bouche surprenant les
patrons 22 dans le village sur la place
du village
ils se choisissent les ouvriers et les
ouvrières évidemment sont bien contents
de trouver du travail
dimanche dernier j'étais en espagne dans
une exploitation de 6 hectares
de légumes en particulier en particulier
de lecture pour les ouvriers le dimanche
matin préparez les machines pour le
lundi matin pour rien c'est à dire
qu'ils n'étaient pas payés et j'étais
bien content de pouvoir commencer lundi
matin en semaine
cela veut-il dire qu'il n'ya aucun moyen
de s'entendre
non affirment les agriculteurs du
roussillon mais il ne faut pas brusquer
les choses
et d'abord établi un calendrier détaillé
des échanges agricoles franco espagnole
c'est à dire le partage du marché dans
le temps ce qu'il faut rechercher dans
l'interview consommateurs ce sont des
complémentarités dans le secteur des
fruits et légumes qui permettent
d'étendre cet égard réductions futures
l'espagne produit dès le mois d'avril
dès le mois de mai en pêche par exemple
et nous pouvons poursuivre notre gamme
nous jusqu'en septembre
le sort des industries agroalimentaires
françaises est directement lié à celui
des agriculteurs
leurs conclusions sont d'ailleurs les
mêmes noms à l'entrée immédiate de
l'espagne dans le marché commun dans
quelques années oui à deux conditions
d'abord que soit respectée la
complémentarité des produits ensuite que
les salaires des ouvriers agricoles de
conserverie cas comparable de chaque
côté des pyrénées les affaires sociales
maintenant journée d'action de la cgt
demain il faut prévoir à tant de
perturbations à la sncf à la ratp aux
ptt mais pas à l'edf puisque vous le
savez la cgt a décidé de ne pas gêner
les usagers il y aura la grève mais sans
coupure de courant
pas de journaux non plus je demain ou
très peu et puis ce soir encore pour le
troisième jour consécutif le quotidien
la croix n'est pas paru à la suite d'une
grève des rotativistes puis des multi
pistes on commence à être inquiet pour
ce journal du soir
et puis dans la sidérurgie journée
d'action aujourd'hui à valenciennes et
dans toute la région
hier ce fait l'opération ville morte à
longwy
demain ce sera le cas à denain
or ce sont là les trois régions les plus
touchées par cette crise dans la
sidérurgie
où l'avez vu dans à valenciennes
manifestation un haut fonctionnaire chez
agache villo jacques darmon 38 ans
dirigera donc le premier groupe textile
français politique maintenant
d'abord les suites de ce qu'on appelle
la sphère peyrefitte le garde des sceaux
a en effet été sanctionné hier pour la
manière dont il s'est opposé à jacques
chirac
on parle de six mois de suspension du
rpr mais il faudra que la commission des
conflits a valid à moins qu'un pardon
venu d'euros plusieurs députés se sont
émus de cette sanction envers mes paires
cite par exemple
etienne pinte les yvelines et jacques
piot de l'yonne toujours à l'assemblée
discours de clôture de la session
ordinaire aujourd'hui chercheur delmas
souhaite une meilleure consommation avec
le gouvernement mais se félicite de
l'amélioration des relations entre
majorité et opposition et raymond barre
lui dans sa réponse se félicite des
débats qui ont été menées notamment à
tenir celui de la défense nationale qui
a permis au site de renforcer
l'indépendance à laquelle tout le monde
en france est attachée
enfin au parti socialiste nouvelle
réunion aujourd'hui de tarification tous
ceux qui ont soutenu françois mitterrand
à nantes sont actuellement encore en
réunion à tout moment bien sûr nos les
copains peut nous appeler
il semble quand même que pour l'instant
on se dirige vers une alliance de fait
entre pierre mauroy et michel rocard
cela voudrait donc dire que le député
maire de lille a choisi de s'opposer en
quelque sorte à françois mitterrand mais
je vous le répète ma réunion n'est pas
tout à fait terminée tout peut encore
arriver à conakry en fête fut murs
repeints drapeaux aux fenêtres calicots
et banderoles dans les rues la guinness
préparait depuis un mois à accueillir le
chef de l'état français et comme prévu
ce matin à l'arrivée du concorde
ce fut après vingt ans de bully
l'enthousiasmé d'une fouille évalué à
plus de 100 milles de concorde à la
minute précise fixée par le protocole
11h30 30 degrés à l'ombre
l aéroport de conakry retaper en
catastrophe comme laura était depuis
deux semaines toute la capitale
une image que l'on n'aurait sans doute
pas imaginé il n'y a encore que quelques
mois le président de la france pauthe à
côte avec le président à vie de la
république de guinée valéry giscard
d'estaing et sékou touré le leader
africain sans doute le plus imprévisible
le plus fougueux dans les rues de
conakry
l'homme qu'il y a quelques mois à peine
c'est justement réconcilier avec ses
deux ennemis de toujours
léopold senghor sénégal et au poids de
bonis côte d'ivoire un virage politique
pour la guinée après vingt ans
d'isolement qui a précédé les
retrouvailles d'aujourd'hui avec paris
une longue page d'histoire que l'on a
déjà presque oublier du moins pour les
quelques milliers de guinéens qui se
trouvait ce matin sur le parcours du
cortège officiel
comme si la france les français
n'avaient pas vraiment quitté ce pays
depuis 1958
ou peut-être aussi avec ce sentiment de
fierté parce qu'aujourd'hui en 78 après
vingt années d'indépendance la guinée
peut offrir à ses nouveaux alliés du
monde occidental
quelques-unes des plus importantes
richesses minières d'après ce plan qu'il
pourra retenir trois idées trois points
de ce voyage premier point c'est la
réconciliation officielle entre deux
pays quelque peu brouillé depuis 20 ans
deuxième point au travers de cette
réconciliation la reprise des accords
économiques
s'il est vrai que conakry a aujourd'hui
besoin de paris il est vrai aussi que
paris a aujourd'hui besoin de conakry
troisième point plus utile celui là la
question des droits de l'homme d'un
discours prononcé c'est pas vieux il y à
peine un mois par sékou touré devant
l'assemblée du peuple
j'ai retenu une page on nous reproche
d'avoir exécuté quelques ministres
quelques officiers supérieurs
même s'il y a des centaines de ministres
et d'officiers traîtres à leur patrie le
peuple guinéen s'en débarrassera
définitivement pour que la nation
demeure à jamais libre et souveraine
il est certain que l'elysée a décidé
d'aborder ici à conakry tous les points
y compris la question des droits de
l'homme
avec cette position de base les plus
efficaces de parler de droits de l'homme
lorsqu'on est à l'intérieur d'un pays
plutôt que de le faire à 5000 km de
distance
daniel cohn-bendit fêtera noël en france
christian bonnet a signé ce matin
l'arrêté le vent la mesure
d'interdiction qui frappe est belle île
rouge depuis neuf ans daniel cohn-bendit
a aujourd'hui 33 ans il a bien accueilli
ce cadeau de noël mais n'a pas pour
l'instant l'intention de s'installer en
france mars 1968 daniel cohn bendit
frappe les trois coups d'une révolte qui
va gagner la france entière le petit
rouquin de nanterre va rapidement
prendre le pas sur ses compagnons
jacques sauvageau et hallinger smar
porte-parole des enragés puis porte
parole quasi officiel de mai 68 daniel
cohn bendit devient une vedette que la
presse s'arrachent le 24 mai 68 monsieur
fouchette ministre de l'intérieur le
fait expulser du territoire français
dany le rouge devient dany le banni dix
ans ont passé
les nostalgiques de mai-68 ressemblent
un peu à des anciens combattants la
france a eu depuis deux présidents de la
république et cinq premiers ministres
cohn bendit a demandé plusieurs fois
sans succès la levée de l'interdiction
qui le frappait en septembre dernier
pourtant le président de la république
indiqué que le problème cohn bendit ne
resterait pas sans solution attentat ce
matin à jérusalem six blessés en
représailles l'aviation israélienne a
bombardé un camp palestinien sud liban
cinq morts et une cinquantaine de
blessés dans une collision ferroviaire
hier soir à breitenau sud de
l'angleterre plusieurs passagers sont
encore prisonniers de l'amas de
ferraille le choc fut si violent que
vous ne voyez la voiture de tête du
second train a littéralement avalé les
derniers wagons du premier convoi sur
place une quarantaine d'hommes
lens essaie toujours de dégager les
blessés la page sportive maintenant avec
tout d'abord les pronostics de pierrette
brès pour le tiercé qui se disputera
demain à vincennes voici ces élus donc
le 11 le 16 le 15
le 10 le 5 le 1 et le 6 les pronostics
donc de pièces bref et puis le football
entreprise c'est pour bientôt avec un
projet de statut d'économie mixte pour
le club de l'ict de l'île bardon pierre
mauroy l'a annoncé au cours d'une
réunion à laquelle assistaient quelques
maire socialiste gaston defferre pour
marseille alain chénard pour nantes
et pour le maire de lille c'est la
meilleure façon de gérer l'un des plus
beaux spectacles mais il semble qu'il ya
une petite erreur effectivement que tu
veux voir un sujet sur l'île et je pense
que nous allions voir un sujet sur la
médecine je peux vous en parler de la
médecine s'agit du laser le laser qui
est au secours de la médecine avec
l'endoscopie
4e sorte il fera et passionnant qu'est
ce qu'on pouvait acheter une minute
décidément il y a quelque chose de
changé au royaume d'antenne 2 et je
voulais vous parler du laser et je vous
en parlerai parce que le laser va venir
au secours de la médecine au secours de
la santé lors de skopies vous le savez
c'est une méthode d'observation médical
et bien un endoscope muni d'un rayon
laser a permis à une équipe médicale de
toulouse de prêts les prêts en
profondeur dans un geste
regardez quand un ulcère de l'estomac se
met à saigner
il faut faire vite très vite chaque
minute compte pour venir en aide à un
malade qui se vide de son sang
et pour arrêter à tout prix une
hémorragie qui peut être mortelle or
jusqu'à présent le seul recours était
d'opérer en urgence donc dans les pires
conditions des malades souvent âgées est
toujours très affaiblie avec pour
conséquence un risque de mortalité et
narry et ce malgré les progrès
importants des méthodes de diagnostic en
effet des sondes lumineuse flexible des
endoscopes permettent depuis quelques
années sans opération d'observer
l'intérieur du tube digestif
ces anomalies ces lésions ces
saignements
mais malgré leurs prouesses multiples
ces appareils étaient totalement
impuissant pour arrêter l'hémorragie
qu'ils étaient capables de revevol
aujourd'hui tout peut changer
l'adaptation sur l'endoscope d'un rayon
laser permet d'aller avec la sonde
arrêté dans l'estomac l'écoulement de
sang comme on le voit ici nettement
filmé chez un animal en expérience
depuis trois mois à toulouse dans le
service du professeur ribes et un
endoscope muni d'un laser commencent à
traiter les hémorragies digestives
humaine
voilà ici il s'agit d'un ulcère qui sen
sommes en train à l'aide d'un jet de gaz
carbonique d'écarter le sens de cette
île soeur on va diriger le faisceau
pilote sur l'ulcère
voilà en fait passer le laser
l'hémorragie est arrêté c'est ce même
procédé qui a été utilisé voici trois
semaines pour sauver une femme très âgée
arrivé en urgence du fond de la campagne
après plusieurs hémorragies nixon est
arrivé tôt une goût j'ai eu du sinaï
comme une des cinq années j'ai dit c'est
pas normal ça c'est quelque chose chez
nissan l'endoscope a permis de repérer
le g2 san puis le laser la cohabiter
vingt jours plus tard la malade va mieux
mais sans danger sans douleur on va le
contredire
approché la tête voilà respire et fort
par le nez respirait bien par l'onea
vallée voilà il est passé
respirez bien un peu gênant au moment de
la première déglutition parfois
inconfortable mais pas douloureux
l'examen qui n'exige aucune préparation
spéciale peut être fait surtout malade
et se répéter sans danger
1les y en ait complètement cicatrisée
tout est parfait c'est parfait oui
restait plus de trace de ce nouveau
seuil il n'y avait pas eu de laser vous
n'auriez pas pu opérer ces dames il
aurait il fallu l'opérer en urgence et
connaissons pas l'issue y aurait il de
cette intervention
ces examens sont dans l'ensemble très
bien toléré et là il était nécessaire de
le répéter pour connaître l'évolution du
statut serre et pour s'assurer de sa
guérison
actuellement quel est le vôtre malade le
prix âgées et bien si cette malade qui a
85 ans voilà c'est fini madame schaub
vous êtes guéri
avec le laser le cap difficile est passé
mais si l'ulcère ne saignent plus il
n'est pas toujours guéri pour autant il
faudra donc le traiter au fond mais
cette fois sans urgence et sous l'oeil
attentif de l'endoscope pour qui le
laser n'est qu'une arme de poing temps
plus dans une panoplie multiples de
diagnostic et de traitement
voilà le loto maintenant comme chaque
mercredi le 50e du nom voici donc la
combinaison gagnante le 8 le 31 le 35-40
le 41 et le 49 numéro complémentaire
vous le voyez le 27 à l'ats michel
lalande a peu fait le tri dans tous les
sujets qui nous embouteillée qui
arrivait en cascade comme promis donc
maintenant l'initiative du maire de
lille qui a doté son équipe de football
d'un statut d'économie mixte regardez ce
ballon symbolise la première société
française d'économie mixte chargée de la
gestion d'un club de football
pierre mauroy le maire de la ville vient
d'obtenir l'agrément du ministre de la
jeunesse et des sports pour prendre en
charge la section professionnelle du
lille olympique le capital d'un total de
1 million se partage en trois tranches
49% fournis par la municipalité 35%
fournis par le club le lille olympique
enfin 16 % provenant des sponsors
publicité maillot trois raisons ont
conduit la municipalité à agir dans ce
sens la reconnaissance du phénomène
football et du fai professionnels
l'importance du spectacle offert à une
ville c'est la concerne vingt mille
personnes en moyenne
enfin delà du sport c'est une
manifestation sociale est une forme de
communication
selon pierre mauroy le football
professionnel français est prisonnier du
show-business que sa seule issue réside
dans le principe de cette société
d'économie mixte qui amènera au football
français
plus de clarté plus de rigueur le
partage des responsabilités et des
charges nécessitera néanmoins beaucoup
de confiance entre la mairie et les
dirigeants certains maires socialistes
intéressé par l'initiative de pierre
mauroy estimé en revanche qu'une
municipalité doit contrôler
l'utilisation de ces fonds et nous les
gérer elles mêmes l'expérience donnera
peut-être une réponse à l'alternative
dans quatre jours la veillée de noël
noël les cadeaux que l'on reçoit ce que
l'on offre les achats la publicité et
souvent donc une fête de la consommation
mais on peut encore si on cherche bien
trouver un cadeau merveilleux
nous avons pour notre part des niches et
à l'institut des tournelles près de
paris un établissement pour enfants
moins privilégiés que les autres à qui
le père noël a rendu visite avec
quelques jours d'avancé et en utilisant
vos loyers un véhicule de tête un peu
moins poétique que le traîneau mais plus
efficace un hélicoptère
ap
voilà il par la faute de tout notre
petit plat ne vous avez déjà vu deux
fois donc ce sujet mais c'est très bien
c'est driss la météo maintenant temps
froid aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble du pays
ce nuage avec pluie sur le littoral
méditerranéen et sur la corse pour
demain et bien même type de temps froid
gelées matinales nuage abondant parfois
accompagnés de neige en montagne en fin
de soirée vers 23h30 c'est avec l'autre
qui vous présentera les gagnants des
informations point final à la dernière
émission je vous remercie de votre
attention est passé une très bonne
soirée si possible écoute de nos
programmes à demain
oh